Speaker 1: Well, the Trump riots have hit Brazil
as insurrectionists are committing very similar
sorts of acts as what we saw on January six, 2021,
in the United States, demanding the return of
former President Jair Bolsonaro, who is in Florida
having chicken at KFC and walking around a Publix
supermarket. I know, I know. We are going to get
to all of it. But when we say the actions of Trump
and his cronies following the 2020 election, in
part due to the lack of consequences that they
suffered, will encourage and will normalize the
same type of behavior in other places. And that
is exactly what we are now seeing in Brazil. The
Associated Press reports pro Bolsonaro rioters
storm Brazil's top government offices. We have
incredible video of all sorts. And it looks like
January 6th. It. It is a version of January six,
which we will get to. AP reporting. Supporters
of former Brazilian President Bolsonaro,
who refused to accept his election defeat,
stormed Congress. You could just replace Trump
and Trump supporters there. The Supreme Court and
the presidential palace. On Sunday, a week after
the inauguration of his leftist rival, President
Lula. Thousands of demonstrators bypassed security
barricades, climbed on roofs, smashed windows and
invaded all three buildings, which were believed
to be largely vacant. On the weekend, some of the
demonstrators called for a military intervention.
Wow. Where we have have we heard that before? To
either restore the far right Bolsonaro to power
or oust Lula from the presidency? Hours went by
before control of the buildings on Brasilia.
Vast three Power square was reestablished,
with hundreds of the participants arrested.
And we're going to talk about that as well
in a news conference from Sao Paulo. Lula accused
Bolsonaro of encouraging the uprising by those he
termed fascist fanatics. And he read a freshly
signed decree for the federal government to take
control of security in the federal district,
saying, quote, There is no precedent for what
they did and these people need to be punished.
Let's take a look at some of the stunning,
stunning video. Here is one in which you will
see and let's see if I can get the volume right.
We'll keep the volume lower. In this one, you
see folks who have gotten through the police
barricade, you quite literally see the fencing.
They're down on the ground, invaded the Congress
ramp. They threatened to occupy the chamber
and the Senate, which they subsequently did.
They subsequently did these videos. Different
setting, different weather, that's for sure.
But looking very, very much like January 6th here
in the United States. In another video continuing
to look just like what we saw on January six, the
Bolsonaro does invaded the floor of the federal
Senate and they're wearing different clothes. You
don't see the Cuban on Shaman, but you see a very,
very similar looking event as to what we saw
on January 6th in the House of Representatives.
Yeah, the imagery, as we continue looking here, is
more imagery where you will see and I'm trying to
get the audio mix just right so you can hear
me. This looks like January 6th. They have
flags. They approach police. They knock down the
barriers. In this case, police take out some kind
of an irritant. Sprayed appears, but the rioters
overwhelm the police in the sense that they break
the barrier and they continue moving on into the
buildings. Where have we seen this before? I mean,
it is just another example of the same thing
again. Now, it is really important to understand
not only how can I say this in a general
sense, we know where they got this idea.
We know where they got this idea because
we saw it here on January six, 2021. It's
been two years and three days since that took
place. But it's also important to understand
that Bannon, Steve Bannon and other Trump aides
were advising Jair Bolsonaro in November about
how to proceed. This is an article I have on
the screen from The Washington Post. The date
is November 23rd, and we're going to deal with
this in more detail a little bit later. Trump
aides Bannon, Miller advising the Bolsonaro's on
next steps. Next steps. What do you mean? Well,
you know, instigate a riot, an insurrection. Some
allies and advisers writes the article, want the
Brazilian president to contest his election loss
to Lula. Others want a global fight over. Free
speech. And you can read this and we're going to
look at it a little bit more later. So I won't
delve into it that much right now. But this is the
playbook. They helped them develop the playbook
and we should not be surprised when the same
inputs give you very similar outputs. Now, what
is necessary here? Is for the military to say that
they unconditionally support Lula as the legally
elected president. And you all know I absolutely
despise Bolsonaro. And I'm not a big fan of
Lula. I've told you my issues with Lula before. I
think Lula is better than Bolsonaro. But that's a
separate question from who is the legally elected
president. And the legally elected president is
Lula. So the military and maybe by the time we
go to air with this, it will have happened. I
don't know if it has. As of right now, it hasn't
happened, which is why I'm saying it. The military
should say Lula's the legal president. Don't
come to us for any sort of ideas about a coup or
help with the insurrection. Lula's the president,
period. Now, unfortunately, there are many in the
Brazilian military who are very much anti Lula.
And when you know that that's the case, until you
hear that unconditional statement of support, you
wonder whether it's actually coming. This is in
part what happens when the people who tried this
here were seriously punished. And by that I mean
the instigators and the agitators I know. Q And on
Shaman got four years or whatever, I get it. But
big picture all the way up to Trump the people who
created this environment and stimulated exactly
what went down. They have not been punished. So.
So this is what happens. One difference, arguably,
that we're already seeing is that the mass arrests
have started in Brazil. Now, are they fully
capturing all the lawbreakers yet? We don't know.
But scores have already been arrested after they
showed up and they did this. The things that I
showed you doing on the show, them doing on video,
and while there were, of course, eventually
hundreds of arrests here in the United States.
At the immediate time, there was not that show
of we're arresting all of you and throwing you
all on a bus. And quite literally, that's what's
been happening with a lot of these rioters who,
quite frankly, are terrorists in Brazil. And
so that's a difference. We'll see if we get a
statement from the military and we'll see where
this ultimately shakes out. Now, in the midst of
all this, you might be wondering, David, where
is Jair Bolsonaro? Well, he's in Florida eating
chicken at KFC and looking around at a Publix. And
that is exactly what I want to talk about next.